- [Woman] So, we got you something.
- [Man] Aww, what is it?
(playful music)
- [Woman] Come on, open it up.
- [Man] Oh, okay.
Thanks?
- [Woman] No, honestly, this little guy
is a big deal in Catalonia.
To explain why, we gotta head
to Torroella de Montrgrí,
a town in the Catalonia region of Spain
and to Barcelona, a little later.
But anyways, back to
Torroella de Montrgrí,
home to this man, no no no wait, this one.
(speaking foreign language)
Caga, what?
In English?
- To shit.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Woman] In Catalonia, when
you put up your nativity scene,
you have Mary, Joseph,
of course, Baby Jesus,
some Kings and this guy,
yep, the caganer.
(speaking foreign language)
So, in someone's home,
(knocking)
there he is.
In this museum, there he is.
Whoa, there's even one in
this street nativity scene.
Okay, this is definitely not a joke.
Can we now talk about
your latest business idea?
(dramatic epic music)
(speaking foreign language)
(playful music)
See?
There you go.
A gift for all year round.